- What's up Believe Nation?
It's Evan, my one word is believe
and I believe that you
have the ability to create
something special that
will change the planet.
To help you on your journey,
I started the Mentor Me series,
and the goal here is to
try to hang around people
who have done a lot more than us,
who have achieved massive success,
and hopefully by hanging around
theme a little bit longer,
some of their mindsets, their
attitudes, their beliefs,
the way they see the
world, will seep into us,
to help us become the
best version of ourselves.
So, today we're going to
learn from Brene Brown,
and the power of
vulnerability and emotions.
Mentor me, Brene.
Rule number three is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
(upbeat music)
- I want to start with two questions,
that I really want you to think about.
And the two questions are,
what should I be afraid of today?
And, who's to blame?
What should scare me
and who's fault is it?
To me, these are the most
profoundly dangerous questions
that we center our lives around.
And, to me, what they are indicators of,
is a culture of scarcity,
a culture of not enough.
And when you think about
any milieu in your life,
think about education.
What are we supposed to be afraid of,
and who's to blame?
Politics, the economy, social issues.
I guarantee you if you turn on the news
or opened a paper today,
the focus would be
here's why you should be afraid
and here's who's fault it is.
What's interesting to me about that,
is it's not just at a cultural
level, or a community level,
that stuff happens in
my house, every week.
Every week, with my husband,
I talk to him about why
we should be fearful
and who's fault it is.
Mostly it's his.
(laughing)
But you know, if something doesn't go well
at my daughter's school,
then I'm like, oh my God,
this is going to have huge
implications for university,
and we should be terrified right now
that she's not getting cursive.
I know she's four,
(laughing)
but this is still relevant.
It's indicative of scarcity.
So let's talk about
what scarcity culture is
and what it looks like.
Scarcity culture is best understood
with the simple question of never enough.
And you can fill in the blanks,
never good enough, safe
enough, certain enough,
perfect enough, relevant
enough, and perhaps, I think,
one of the most dangerous
and insidious messages today,
is never extraordinary enough.
Somehow, in the world we live
in today, an ordinary life
has become synonymous
with a meaningless life.
I've watched it happen,
not only as a researcher,
I'm a qualitative researcher,
so I sit across from people
and look in their eyes
and I have a good sense of
what's going on in their lives.
But, as a university professor,
who's been teaching for the last 17 years,
it's been very clear to
me that extraordinary
means relevant.
And the top one is the big
one, for all of us personally,
never good enough.
Which is shame, which we
all have, on occasion,
that sense that we're not
smart enough, good enough,
perfect enough, loved
enough, promoted enough,
we're not enough.
So what we do in response
to scarcity culture,
I think all of us every day, is this.
We wake up in the morning and we armor up.
And we put it on and we say, I'm
going to go out in the world,
I'm basically going to just kick some ass,
I'm not going to let anyone see who I am,
and in doing so, I can protect myself,
against the things that hurt the most,
judgment, criticism,
fear, blame, ridicule.
I'm going to armor up
and I'm going to be safe.
And we rationalize and
we convince ourselves
that this armor is really smart.
And we use a lot of different
things to armor, too.
Perfectionism, intellectualizing,
but if you get really, really, clear
about what we're doing every morning
when we wake up and decide
to armor, it's this simple.
This is what we're protecting,
We're protecting being hurt,
for a very simple reason,
that no one really wants to
talk about, which is this,
love, belonging, irreducible needs
of men, women, and children.
In the absence of love and belonging,
there's always suffering.
And so what we believe is
that we can protect our sense
of being lovable and being acceptable,
and being worth connection with armor.
Here's the very worst
news from my research,
the news that above all
other, I did not want to hear,
it's simply this, and I don't
even want to say it to you
because I think it's mean to say it.
But it's so true, and it's simply,
our capacity for wholeheartedness
can never be greater
than our willingness to be brokenhearted.
Which is a terrible thing,
but a truthful thing.
That we can only love and be loved
as much as we are willing
to have our heart broken.
And so when we move through
the world like this,
and with our partners, with our children,
with our friends, in classrooms,
with the people who work for us,
with the people we work for,
there are tremendous casualties.
The biggest myth about
vulnerability is that it's weakness.
I think a lot of people
were raised to believe that.
It was modeled, certainly in our culture,
we see that a lot.
To be vulnerable, to
be open, to be exposed,
is to be weak.
And the truth is, what
I found in my research,
is that vulnerability is not weakness.
In fact, I would argue
that it's our greatest
measure of courage.
When we went out an asked
people, what is vulnerability,
we heard things like,
vulnerability is the first date
after my divorce.
Vulnerability is starting my own company.
Vulnerability is taking
responsibility for something
that went wrong at work.
Vulnerability is sitting with my wife
who has stage three breast cancer
and making plans for our young kids.
Vulnerability is taking
my business public.
The definition I use in
my work, of vulnerability,
is simply uncertainty, risk
and emotional exposure.
Vulnerability is about the
willingness to show up,
and to be seen, even when
there are no guarantees.
It's interesting to me, one
of the things that I thought
was really interesting, I gave a talk,
it's probably a couple of years now,
and it was being
translated by people doing
American Sign Language.
They came up before the
talk started and they said,
are there any words that
you're going to use a lot
in your talk that we should know about
that might be different.
And, I said, well I use the
word vulnerability a lot.
There were two of them, they
kind of looked at each other
and they said, oh, we do
this, for vulnerability.
And I said, what does that mean?
They said it means weak in the knees.
I'm like, wow, that's not how
I talk about vulnerability.
And she said there's only one
other sign for vulnerability.
And I said, what is it.
And she said,
And, I said, oh, that's
what I'm talking about.
And, so, to me, vulnerability
is our most accurate
measure of courage.
I mean it's pretty powerful
when I have 13,000 pieces of data
collected over 12 years,
that I cannot find a single
incident or story of courage,
that was not completely
underpinned by vulnerability.
I think the problem arises that
there's so many little
paradoxes with vulnerability
and one of them is that
vulnerability is courage in you,
but weakness in me.
When I meet you, it's the
first thing I look for in you.
But it's the last thing
I want to show you in me.
And, so, I think, to really
put ourselves out there,
knowing that if we do that
enough, we're going to fail,
I just don't think it gets
more courageous than that.
If I roughly took the
people I interviewed,
and divided them into people
who really have a sense of worthiness,
that's what this comes down
to, a sense of worthiness,
they have strong sense
of love and belonging,
and folks who struggle for it,
and folks who are always
wondering if they're good enough,
there was only one variable
that separated the people
who have a strong sense
of love and belonging
and really struggle for
it, and that was the people
who have a strong sense
of love and belonging
believe they're worthy
of love and belonging.
That's it.
They believe they're worthy.
And, to me, the hard
part of, the one thing
that keeps us out of connection,
is our fear that we're
not worthy of connection
was something that personally
and professionally,
I felt like I needed to understand better.
So, what I did, is I took
all of the interviews
where I saw worthiness, where
I saw people living that way,
and just looked at those.
What do these people have in common?
And I have a slight
office supply addiction,
but that's another talk.
(laughing)
So, I had a manila folder
and I had a sharpie,
and I was like, what am I
going to call this research?
The first words that came to
my mind were wholehearted.
These are wholehearted
people, living from this deep
sense of worthiness.
So, I wrote at the top
of the manila folder,
and I started looking at the data.
In fact, I did it at first,
in a four day, very intensive,
data analysis, where I went
back, pulled these interviews,
pulled these stories,
pulled the incidents,
what's the theme, what's the pattern?
My husband left town with the kids,
(laughing)
because I always go into this
Jackson Pollock crazy thing,
where I'm just writing
and in my researcher mode.
And so, here's what I found.
What they had in common,
was a sense of courage.
And I want to separate courage and bravery
for you for a minute.
Courage, the original
definition of courage,
when it first came into
the English language,
it's from the Latin
word cor, meaning heart,
and the original definition
was to tell the story
of who you are with your whole heart.
And so these folks had very simply,
the courage to be imperfect.
They had the compassion to
be kind to themselves first,
and then to others,
because as it turns out,
we can't practice compassion
with other people,
if we can't treat ourselves kindly.
And the last was they had connection,
and this was the hard part,
as a result of authenticity.
They were willing to let
go of who they thought they
should be, in order to be who they were,
which you have to absolutely
do that for connection.
The other thing that they
had in common was this,
they fully embraced vulnerability.
They believed that what
made them vulnerable,
made them beautiful.
They didn't talk about
vulnerability being comfortable,
nor did they really talk
about being excruciating,
as I had heard it earlier
in the shame interviewing,
they just talked about it being necessary.
They talked about the willingness
to say I love you first.
The willingness to do something
where there are no guarantees.
The willingness to breathe
through the waiting
for the doctor to call
after your mammogram.
Be willing to invest in a relationship
that may or may not work out.
They thought this was fundamental.
Let me tell you this real
story, this just happened.
I spoke at HubSpot last week.
OK, 13,000 in this
Boston convention center.
It's like 10 minutes before I go on,
and I look at Twitter and this
person sends this tweet out
that says, why is Brene at HubSpot?
Why is @brenebrown at HubSpot 2015?
And he had just tweeted love Seth Godin,
love Amy Schumer, all these people but,
why is Brene Brown?
And I'm like, oh, my
God, why am I at HubSpot?
What am I doing here?
(laughing)
And the, I start sweating and even though
it's a convention center,
it's like, ladies,
and I'm like, oh my God, what am I doing?
And I'm the opening keynote
and then, he tweets it again.
And, I'm like, oh my God.
These are marketing people,
I don't know anything.
So I start Googling on my
phone, marketing terms 2015.
(laughing)
Wait, the first term that
comes up is incentivize,
I'm like, I've got to
work the word incentivize
into this keynote.
I'm like, what does that
mean exactly, I don't know,
(laughing)
but I'm going to say, we're
going to incentivize, I'm like,
what is happening, and I have
a total crisis of confidence.
Shame drives two tapes, not good enough
and who do you think you are?
I'm like, who, who am I?
Right, snaps, terrible.
Then all of a sudden, I'm like, who is it?
Because what happens when
you get backed into a corner?
My brain is making up this story,
you don't belong here.
I'm like that story is not going to work
because I'm going on in five seconds.
(laughing)
OK, the best case scenario, attack,
Attack, attack this guy.
Maybe attack him from the stage.
Maybe you that as my opening.
- Damn.
- Maybe say, like, John Doe,
asks what I'm going here.
Well let me tell ya'll.
And then I click on
the tweet to figure out
what his name is, and I
accidentally hit the link
in his tweet, and it goes to this page
that says, what is Brene
Brown doing at HubSpot?
She's talking about vulnerability
and that's so important.
Here's her TedTalk,
(laughing)
here are her books.
Could you imagine if I would have
gone out there and been like,
a creep?
- Dear jerk,
(laughing)
- Totally, and that's a true
story, it just happened.
So what happens is when
something hard happens,
and we're captured by something difficult,
our emotions get the first
crack at making sense
of something, a bad
look, a hard phone call,
a disagreement at work.
We think that we're rational beings,
we think that cognition is
going to carry us through
and make sense of it, but it doesn't.
You know, emotion's driving,
thought and behavior
are not even in the front
seat riding shotgun,
they're not even in the backseat.
Thought and behavior in
the trunk, going, hey,
and emotion's driving.
So the first thing we do, is
we tell ourselves a story,
that reduces ambiguity
about what happened.
Oh, I'm not supposed to be here,
I'm not good enough to be here,
men and women who have
the greatest capacity
for rising strong, in the
moment something happens,
they hack into that
neuro-biological process
of making up a story.
They stop and say, wait a minute,
what's actually going on here?
What am I feeling, what
do I know for sure?
What is a story?
There's a name in research for story,
that has one or two limited data points
and we fill in the rest with fear.
It's called a conspiracy.
(laughing)
A conspiracy is a story
with limited data points.
so here's what I know, I
know a guy sent a tweet,
I know I'm getting ready
to talk, that's all I know>
So, now that I'm ready to ruin his career,
and use him as a whipping
person as I talk.
What is going on?
The first step of rising strong is
recognize you've been snagged by emotion
and get curious about it.
That's it.
But how many of you
were raised in families
where you were encouraged to get curious
about your emotions and talk
about them and explore them?
(laughing)
Versus how many of you
were raised in families
where you were taught, hey, suck it up?
Push through and get it done.
So the first thing is really
reckoning with emotion.
What am I feeling, and what
do I need to know more about?
And, so that thing that you
say, does someone know something
that I don't know?
Do they have information I don't have?
That's a huge part of the reckoning.
We just don't do it.
So in that minute, in the back stage,
when I was on my phone,
I could have just said,
whoa, Brene, your heart is racing,
your teeth are clenched,
and you're going in for the kill here.
What do you know about this?
Nothing.
You know nothing.
And what if you knew
everything, who cares?
Who gives a ?
There are 13,000 people,
you're going to spend an hour,
targeting one guy you don't know?
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know what did
you learn from this video,
that you're going to
immediately apply, somehow,
to your life or your business?
What was the single most
important lesson that you learned?
Leave it down in the comments below,
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Mike Markham.
Mike, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and doing
the review on restaurant-hr.
I really, really appreciate
the support Mike,
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed my book.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you.
I hope you can continue
to believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.